just when you thought 20/20 couldn't get
any more wild I have decided in 2020 to
run for president
Kanye West is actually making good on
that promise from 2015 the world would
be a better place on Saturday the rapper
dropped the news on Twitter writing we
must now realize the promise of America
by trusting God unifying our vision and
building our future I am running for
president of the United States
hashtag 2020 vision this is one that
could be President Kanye already has
some votes from his famous friends Elon
Musk who was one of the first to weigh
in tweeted you have my full support
Mark Cuban analyzed his changes posting
if there was a ranked choice voting
available in Kanye West was on the
ballot with Joe Biden and Donald Trump I
would have Kayne West ahead of Donald
Trump NFL player Dez Bryant is all in
tweeting I'm voting for Kanye West I
didn't judge you on your vote don't
judge me on mine I'm so happy that it's
been well received because you know I've
seen him go through a lot and he's just
the most genuine person and you know he
might say things that might get
misinterpreted and
people don't see the context behind it
but I always know his heart and
potential future first lady Kim
Kardashian of course had her husband's
back by retweeting his message with the
American flag others however weren't as
stoked by Kanye's announcement I'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
Piers Morgan tweeted not now Kanye
seriously Octavia Spencer threw shade at
the rapper writing it's obvious that
some people live in a bubble it's about
time to burst it hashtag 20/20 vision
bachelor alum Wells Adams through some
humor while toni braxton Hilary Duff and
Paris Hilton also announced their
campaigns facetiously posh talks live
and this isn't the first time Kanye has
shared his presidential ambitions the 43
year old previously announced he
intended to run for president back in
2015 at the MTV VMAs while accepting his
video Vanguard Award at the time
President Donald Trump even told Rolling
Stones that he fully supports Kanye he's
actually a different kind of a person
than people think he's a nice guy
I hope to run against him someday but as
the primary elections have been taking
place and the 2020 presidential election
is now four months away the rapper
hasn't made it clear that he intends to
be in this year's race until this tweet
so only time will tell if Kanye's
announcement actually comes to fruition
have a responsibility
[Music]